joining us for more perspective on the
pandemic is dr uzma syed an infectious
disease specialist
and head of the kovid task force at good
samaritan hospital in long island new
york
dr syed good morning i know you have
been in the thick of it
at one point working at three different
hospitals 16 hour shifts
give us some perspective doctor what's
it like inside these hospitals now
good morning elaine um so yeah my
colleagues and i have really been
at the forefront of this pandemic for a
year now and
healthcare workers have been doing this
for a long time and frankly they are
exhausted with the ongoing rising
cases hospitalizations and deaths it
just seems like there's no end in sight
dr syed you say that your peers are
exhausted do you see
any room for improvement that you're
hoping to see in the coming days
or weeks as we continue to fight this
well that's really the message that we
keep getting out to americans is that
you know we each
have a part to play in all of this we're
in this together
the more that people can wear their
masks and socially distance and
just really avoid all those behaviors
that help virus transmission
and especially as everyone is moving
indoors and with the holidays
and with the abundance of travel our
hospitals are already
full of patients and it's really
alarming and you know we still do not
have a cure
that's a medication that's 100 percent
curative of this virus so we want people
to know with over 300 000 people that
have lost their lives
we are doing everything that we can
every day to save lives
you know dr syed i wonder what you would
say to folks who
might be traveling as you think about
your own experience and the experience
of your colleagues who have been on the
front lines
if you could give people advice on what
they might do
when they come home from traveling what
they might do
when they arrive at their destinations
that you think might
mitigate the situation so people like
you
aren't seeing increased cases
absolutely i mean pandemic fatigue is
real we are all feeling it
all of us even in healthcare want our
lives back to normal
more than anyone else for travelers i
would really urge them that a test is
really a snapshot in time
so the best thing to do is to really
quarantine before your departure
and then after your arrival you really
need to quarantine as well because now
you've just had high risk of exposure
so you know having a negative test right
before your travel
does not in fact clear you of infection
because you may be
incubating you may have been exposed
during your travel
so it's really prudent to continue
quarantining after you've arrived at
your destination for
about two weeks doctor parts of england
and south africa are
obviously experiencing this new variant
this new
piece of covid19 if you will that
spreads even more easily than what we've
been talking about for the past
nine months do you see the current
vaccines that we have as being able to
protect against those new variants
there is really good reason to believe
that the vaccines will be effective and
in fact the manufacturers are testing
them because
you know the vaccine produces immunity
in many different ways
so we really have good reason to believe
that the vaccines will be effective
but the most important thing to remember
is that the tools that we have
to fight against transmission of this
virus are still effective against this
variant and those include
wearing a mask socially distancing and
really avoiding
indoor gatherings with people that are
outside of your household
great tips thank you so much dr uzma
saeed we appreciate it